the un inquiry accused the regime of kim
jong-un of widespread crimes against
humanity
the chairperson of the inquiry said they
were sanctioned at the highest level in
north korea
and called for the international
community to take action
contending with the scourges of nazism
apartheid the khmer rouge and other
affronts
required great courage by great nations
and by ordinary human beings alike
it is now your solemn duty to address
the scourge of human rights violations
and crimes against humanity in the
democratic people's republic of korea
but china dismissed the un report
because no information had been gathered
in north korea itself
the inability of the commission to get
support and cooperation from the country
concerned makes it impossible for the
commission to carry out its mandate in
an impartial objective and effective
manner
the eu has called for north korea to be
referred to the international criminal
court
but as a permanent member of the
security council china has the power to
veto any resolution against pyongyang